i
[Música]
ah
para semana santa españa apuesta por el
cierre perimetral esto significa que la
población no se podrá desplazar de una
comunidad autónoma a otra y eso ha hecho
que haya incrementado muchísimo la
demanda del turismo jugar aquí en
cataluña por ejemplo algunas plataformas
registran hasta el 90% de reservas para
esta semana en alojamientos rurales pero
también en el sector turístico critican
mucho estas medidas y las califica de
incongruencias el hecho por ejemplo es
que un turista local no se pueda
desplazar mientras que un turista
europeo alemán o francés por ejemplo
pueda viajar a españa donde quiera
así en los hoteleros piden que se deje
al menos viajar a los españoles en las
provincias donde la incidencia del
covite es más baja pero recuerdan que no
será suficiente ya que más de la mitad
de los hoteles siguen cerrados en
españa'
[Música]
italia se prepara a vivir una semana
santa inédita ante el repunte de
contagios de coronavirus el gobierno
italiano ha decidido aplicar un
confinamiento estricto durante el fin de
semana de pascuas sólo se podrá salir de
la casa por urgencias o necesidades
básicas una medida que afecta
particularmente el sector del turismo ya
que los desplazamientos entre diferentes
regiones del país están prohibidos y
para poder entrar a italia los turistas
extranjeros deberán presentar un test de
coronavirus con resultados negativo en
las últimas 48 horas anteriores a la
entrada al país en caso de no poder
cumplir estos requisitos los viajeros
deberán someterse a un confinamiento de
14 días se estima que el sector de
turismo ha perdido más de 1200 millones
de euros a causa de la pandemia aquí en
italia
[Música]
estas calles de la medina de marrakech
estarían repletas de locales y
visitantes de todo el mundo de no ser
por la pandemia más aún estando en
temporada alta de turismo como es el
caso en semana santa' pero desde hace un
año aquí en la medina como pueden
observar hay poca actividad y se espera
que siga siendo así durante el periodo
vacacional ya que la mayoría de turistas
que suelen entrar al país son europeos y
sigue habiendo restricciones aéreas
entre marruecos y gran parte de la unión
europea los turistas que decidan venir
tendrán que adaptar sus vacas
no hay libre circulación en todo el
territorio nacional y al toque de queda
a partir de las 9 am de la noche también
cabe tener en cuenta que marruecos es el
país más turístico de áfrica y marrakech
concretamente la ciudad más turística
del país y aunque aquí la campaña de
vacunación avanza con éxito la crisis
económica está siendo muy dura ya sea en
más de un 70 por ciento en la
recuperación se prevé lenta y gran parte
de los trabajadores del sector no
estaban declarados en la caja nacional
de la seguridad social y ahora dependen
de la solidaridad y de las remesas de
los emigrados
[Música]